42 friday morning we are celebrating
national donut day
with both d-o-u-g-h
and d-o-n-u-t
u-t yes
ron futron
no matter how you spell it they're
delicious he's taking the donut
challenge going to some of the most
popular shops
in fact ron you're at one of the oldest
donut shops carl's on the east side
i'm going to guess it is the oldest
donuts shop in vegas maybe we saved the
best for last year here since 1966 in
vegas so if you say vegas doesn't have
history come on we have carl's donuts
and there's there's a history um amber
ramsey here is joining us here hi there
how are you this morning okay you were
hopping today you you knew it was
national donut day didn't you national
donut day is our biggest day and it's
like the best most fun day
anything anything special today that
you're doing we are doing ube croissants
we're doing um if you buy any merch you
get entered in to win um a raffle for
free donuts for a year yep yep free
donuts for a year doughnuts for a year
you really want me to go off my diet yes
i do
have some diet i'm not really on a diet
okay what do we have here tell us what
we got we have our creme brulee cinnamon
roll our cannoli old-fashioned a samoa
donut a raspberry and cream or ube
croissant which is a bestseller we
always sell out of that and then we have
our raspberry chocolate truffle what
should i try i'm going to say the creme
brulee cinnamon roll that's pretty
unique to us and it was featured on the
cooking channel this this that one
okay we're on it we're on it crim
criminal
they've all been great this morning this
one's fantastic absolutely great um no
this is marvelous um help you're busy
you guys are hopping already this
morning yes we um it's our busiest day
of the year so we're super excited
okay very good how many donuts you
expect to do today oh
a typical day at carl's is like 70 000
at our wholesale so we're not going to
reach that but i think we're going to be
pretty busy and you guys send them all
over the valley to places too not just
your retail but you guys do it for
businesses and that sort of stuff we do
local casinos convenience stores schools
hospitals all over the place you can get
carl's since 1966. thank you appreciate
your time here i do have a quick story i
have to tell here i had to rush from
glazed donuts to get here i didn't have
enough time got pulled over by a nice
police officer because i was going like
two or three miles an hour over the
speed limit
so
bad news about the donuts that i was
going to bring back for everybody
is that how you get out of there
you know what happened
i gave them to the
the nice police officer i'm not going to
name him but i gave him to the nice
police officer so he has them now i
don't know if that's bribery is it
bribery what do you think we end up
everyone else's day maybe he'll be in a
good mood he'll be in a good
okay okay so so we do have some carl's
donuts we're bringing back is that okay
with everybody i think we we're good
except for this one i'm finishing really
delicious creme brulee he said love it
right oh these are for who uh who dave
who's are the who who are these donuts
for do you know
these are for who come on over dave the
owner is
these are these are for nate hannonball
of course they saved the best for last
there these are for date these are for
you you all right with that
i hope so yeah we got a whole box back
there just for him and we got these two
i can't wait
and they're saying yes
i can't see him but he's saying yes yes
thank you he's excited ron thank you
very much sir enjoy coming back busy
morning everybody over again yeah slow
down on those roads ron